hi i have a question for you
can you read the title of this lecture
yeah
and how about now isn't it a little bit
more difficult
so this is how i see it
blurry and it's significantly harder for
me to read this text
so hi again i'm asia from
i have a bachelor's degree in
computational biology and a master's
degree in computer science
i live in israel and i work as an
algorithm developer for a small startup
called the vinst which is based in tel
aviv
and in my free time i love traveling and
hiking and my love for traveling led me
all the way to antarctica a few years
ago
but until this point i haven't explained
to you why i see blurry
and in order to understand it we need to
go back in time to the moment i was born
because right after i was born i didn't
respond to light stimulations and so the
doctors suspected i might be blind
but after a while it was discovered that
i just don't see well and i was
diagnosed with albinism
so what is albinism albinism is an
inherited condition that manifests
itself in a lack or deficiency in the
pigment melanin and melanin plays a
crucial part in the development of the
eye in the embryonic stage and so people
with albinism tend to have many visual
problems and some of
those problems you can see in those
embarrassing childhood pictures of mine
and
here you can see
problems such as a lazy eye crossed eyes
and you can see the glasses that i wear
from the very first moment i can
remember myself
so what does it mean for me
to be
an albino to be visually impaired in my
everyday life it means that i have
problems reading small text in prints i
have problems reading a text from the
blackboard in the lecture hall and i
have even have problems reading my own
lecture notes when i speak in public as
i do right now
as a computer user i always enlarge the
text in all the programs that i'm using
and many times i struggle to find the
option of the font enlargement
um
option in in the programs that i'm using
as a data scientist i work usually with
visual data and so
many times i try not to rely on my
vision but rather use statistics or the
opinions of people around me
in order to make the right decisions
for my research
however my story is not unique uh as of
2015 there were over 250 million people
over the world that were
visually impaired out of which 217
million people were moderately to
severely
visually impaired and 36 million people
were blind so all those people consume
technology just like anyone else
and there are many tools assistive tools
that help them do so such as screen
readers and magnifying glass software
however
websites and mobile apps need to be
built in a certain way for the assistive
technology
to help those people get their in a full
information
uh from their websites
and
the company i work at events focuses on
digital accessibility and so at events
we believe that accessibility is the
responsibility of the developers and so
we build tools for
developers and for companies that enable
them to incorporate accessibility into
their
products
and
in this way we help
people with who are visually impaired
and people with disability
use the web
better
so
until this point i introduced myself and
i told you a bit about what it means for
me to be visually impaired and let's see
a specific problem that a person who is
visually impaired or colorblind might
face
and
and so
we can see here
two
buttons that are identical in everything
except for the background color of the
button
and the
upper button is light blue and the
lower button is dark blue and the text
overlaid on the buttons is white
and so the color contrast between
the light blue background and the white
background is too low and so a person
who is
visually impaired might not be able to
read the text on the button and so
he might not be able to use
this button and if it it's a part of a
major flow in a website and basically
this flow won't be usable for this
person
and so how do we know if a color
combination is accessible or readable
for people who are visually impaired so
there actually exists a mathematical
function
that
computes the contrast ratio between two
colors
and according to this mathematical
function one can determine if this color
combination is accessible or not
and there exists a standard that
specifies
exactly what should be the color
contrast ratio in different cases for
example where the font size is
18 pixels or 14 pixels if the text is
emphasized or not
and so this is actually like a solved
problem
and however what happens if the text is
overlaid on a complex background such as
a gradient or an image
so in this case the text might blend
into the image and so it won't be
readable and accessible for a person who
is visually impaired
and
in order to assess the the readability
and the accessibility of of the stacks
there are people that whose job
is to assess accessibility of websites
and um they might use this mathematical
function to
calculate contrast ratio for specific
pixels around the text and so
by using this method which is like
manual and text time they might assess
the accessibility of this text however
there is no automatic tool that does
that
and this was my goal
given a
text that that is overlaid on a complex
background
my goal was to classify it into a text
that is
readable
or not readable
okay so
we got the problem definition and let's
see how i started tackling this problem
so first i
tried to use a poc code an existing code
that's relied on synthetic data and
in this code it basically used an ocr
engine called tesseract
so ocr is a technology that enables to
extract text out of images
and um this code worked in the following
way so it got um
an image with a text that was inserted
into it and known text and after that
an ocr engine ran on this image and
extracted a text
and the next step the extracted text was
compared with
the original text that was inserted into
the image and in case they were equal
the text was considered to be
accessible and readable and
if
they weren't equal the text was
considered to be unreadable
so
basically this is the poc idea and i
wanted to test it on real world data the
problem was i didn't have data
and so i had to gather it
and
in order to do so on the web it's fairly
easy to
scrape data and i use my javascript and
my knowledge
of
the way websites are built in order to
scrape pairs of images and text
basically the images showed how the text
looks on the web page and so i tried to
use the methodology i explained on
those pairs
and let's see what i got so here is an
example of a text that is very clear to
us and very readable however tesseract
the ocr engine that i use
returned an empty string
strange right
and here is another example where the
text is very clear and very readable
however tesseract returns uh pure
gibberish
and so i try to understand why i'm
getting those unexpected results and i
dug deeper into a tesseract engine and
the technology and i found out
several interesting facts about sr so
first of all it's an ocr engine that is
meant for
detecting text on
documents meaning black text on a white
background
it has a really nice python
library that wraps it and so it's a
really useful tool for prototyping as it
also supports many languages
and it's actually fairly easy to to
train
tesseract on new languages or new
characters
however
tesseract works best on a high image
quality um
over 300 dpi
whereas the data i got from the web was
72 dpi
which is much lower
to improve tesseract's results one can
perform pre-processing
on
the data such as
transferring the images to black and
white or reducing noise and this can
improve
results however i didn't want to do such
such thing because i suspected that it
might harm my classification
another thing that
affects tesseract is font size and it
performs um
worse on attacks that are really small
and
it also
returns returns strange results on uh
special characters such as currency
signs
so i understood that tesseract is not
the right ocr engine for for my needs
and i started searching for a different
ocr engine
and i stumbled upon a post by jan lee
kuhn who is
the head of ai in meta and one of the
godfathers of deep learning and in his
uh post he recommends a a new ocr engine
called easy ocr which is meant for
detecting a text in the wild meaning
text that exists in a natural scene such
as a
street sign
and so i decided that if
young lacuna recommends something i
should definitely try it
and let's see how easy ocr works so easy
ocr
gets an input image and a does
pre-processing on the image in the next
stage
it performs a text detection
using a model that is called craft
and please remember in a name because
we'll talk about it later
and the next stage is a text recognition
where basically the parts of the image
that
were recognized as text before are
translated into a sequence of characters
and in the last stage
a decoding
process runs and translates the sequence
of characters into
a meaningful
text so
we can see here that easy ocr works
better on the example and we
saw before that tesseract struggled with
and here is another
example where easy ocr works
better
however it's not perfect
and it makes mistakes
on other kinds of
texts such as here we can see that it
makes mistakes on the a percentage sign
and
we can see now what i learned about easy
ocr
so
easy ocr is a an ocr system that is
meant
for detecting tax in the wild
it's based on
by torch which i personally think is a
pro but not everyone would agree
it's a really modular system
and basically each part of the system
can be replaced by a different model
or a different system
and it's really a huge pro in my opinion
and as the name suggests it's
really easy to use there is a really
nice
python library that enables
using
easy ocr for any
ocr requirements
uh the coins
that i saw
were that easy ocr performs worse on
black and white images
where tesseract excels
and it also makes mistakes on special
characters such a dollar signs and
percentage signs and etc
and so
at this point
i came
to a conclusion that
i tried using
two ocr engines tesseract and easy ocr
for my project
and none of them was
suitable for my task i thought about
maybe combining them together into a big
system
or trying a different ocr engine
but i felt that i'm
getting into a bit a more complicated
scenario and
if i would combine a few systems it
would be hard to debug and maintain and
so instead of
going in this direction i did some kind
of
route recalculation and i i decided to
try a different approach
and
the approach that i tried was basically
to use
instead of using a code that existed
before
to use all the knowledge that i got in
the process and incorporate it into my
own solution
and
my solution was based on
three very basic principles
the first one is splitting a big problem
into smaller problems the second one is
using only the relevant existing parts
instead of like big black box systems
and the third one is a
finding the right balance in my data
sets
to get the best model and let's go over
each one of those principles
so the first one
is splitting a big problem into smaller
problems
we can see here
a text and over a complex background
it's written here feel good and um
we can see that the text here is
problematic
um but we can't really quantify it
however
if we look at each character we can
easily um decide that the e
for example is
readable and the o is very not clear and
not readable
and so if we go over each character we
can see that in the stacks we have four
characters that
are not readable out of eight meaning
that the contrast ratio of of or the
ratio of characters with bad contrast is
0.5
and if we have a predefined threshold
for example
as 0.4 before
then we can
see that according to this fresh
threshold this text doesn't pass and so
it we decide that it's
not readable
so the second principle is using only
relevant existing parts so in the
beginning i tried to use
big ocr systems that were composed of
many small pieces and small parts and
when i got unexpected results i couldn't
debug it easily and
so instead of using whole systems as
black boxes i decided to use only a
small part of easy ocr the model craft
in order to
detect and extract
specific characters
and
craft works in the
following way so craft
basically calculates the probability of
each pixel in the image to be in the
center of a character and based on this
probability we can build a heat map
where
the areas
with a high probability would have
would be more red and the areas with low
probability would be more blue
and based on this heat map we can
crop out all the characters into uh
um single a character images
and over each of one of them we can go
with the binary classifier and decide if
each one of those characters is readable
or not
and this leads me to
the third principle which is finding the
right balance in the data set
and so
i decided to model the problem of
classifying a specific character into a
readable or not readable character into
a binary classification problem
um
however
it's actually not really binary as there
exists a scale where
on one side we have a characters that
are very clear and very readable and on
the other side we have characters that
really blend into the background
and
this scale is actually
unique for each person and
whether they are
visually impaired or not
and so
in the beginning i had a set of many
labels
of characters
overlaid on a complex background that
were subjective because
of this scale
and
when i tried to
create a model based on those
labels and my model didn't perform well
and
instead of basing um my model on
subjective labels i decided to enrich my
data set um by using objective labels
where
characters were overlaid on
a plain background and for
this type of data i had a clear standard
standard that defined objectively which
characters are readable and which are
not
and so i did a series of experiments
where i tried to balance
my data um during the training and in
the end i got a model i was satisfied
from
so how does
the whole system work
so the system gets
an input image and a text
and after that
the model craft runs
and
it extracts
basically each character into um
an image a small image
on each one of those characters a binary
classifier runs and classifies each
character into a readable or not
readable character
and
after that we calculate the
the contrast ratio bad contrast ratio
out of the entire characters in the text
and in the end we use a threshold in
order to classify the text
into a readable or not readable text
so
until this point i told you about how i
started
this project of
classifying a text overlaid on the
complex background into a text that is
accessible or not
and in the beginning i tried to
use different ocr architectures to solve
my problem and i told you how i got into
problems using this approach
and so i decided instead of
going
and complicating my solution i decided
to reframe my problem and this led to a
breakthrough and to a solution
and we can see now how it looks in one
of the products
of our company so basically this is
a product called site scanner
it
scans complete domains of our clients
for accessibility issues
and one of the issues that it detects is
the issue that
that i'm talking with you about and so
here we can see some of the results of
text that are really
and not clear and not readable and not
accessible
and
when i run um my system on like big
amounts of data i discovered that this
problem of
attacks that are overlaid on complex
background is more
affect affects more a
specific domain such as traveling and
news and art and design
domains that are
more visual and try to appeal to
the users by using a lot of images
and videos
and
here we can see
some examples of
text that are
were classified as not readable for by
the system and we can see that those
texts are actually not clear and not
readable for
many people
30 million people who are visually
impaired and the solution i showed you
help
helps
all those people in their everyday life
and so i encourage you to think how you
can
incorporate accessibility
into your work either
if it's in how you build your
presentations or create a plot
or even in how you write your code
let's together make the world more
accessible and inclusive to people with
disabilities
[Applause]
so thank you very much essay we have one
uh question in slider from severlet uh
how does your uh how does your approach
account for different kind of color
blindness are there modified contrast
ratio formulas for that yeah so
oh no you can okay yeah sorry
okay
so actually the um
the mathematical function that i
talked about in the beginning for
contrast ratio also incorporates
people who are
color blind and so it incorporates it
into the calculation
however it
it's an area that is invo evolving and
there are many improvements to be done
and so there are standards and they
improve all the time so i hope it would
be better in the future
yeah next question uh what can python
developers do to increase uh visual
accessibility
yeah so actually it's a really good
question
um there are many rules um for
creating uh things that are or plots
that are accessible for example like
some basic rules are
for example not to use a
green and red in the same plot because
people who are color blind can't really
distinguish between them
other things are like using larger
phones and
um and also
add
instead of like code coding something
with color
um adds
another um another option on not to use
only color but also text or more
information because
some people don't see color well and so
they they lose this information
um
can you recommend maybe some resource
for the like where we can find these
roles like how to educate ourselves
yeah so uh there the standard is called
the wcag or wecog
and
basically the the current standard is
2.2
i i think if i'm not mistaken and there
you can see
all the guidelines
they're quite cryptic
to people that really are not in the
field
but uh there are many blog posts about
this topic and so um
you can
go online and
look for the information yeah at least
start with something yeah yeah and i
think that will be unfortunately the
last question
uh does a border around characters help
even even if they have everything
yeah so actually yeah
there is like a
specific spec
wcag specification for that
and it depends on the border
like it should be like
two pixels or more and depends on the
size of the border but yeah it's really
specific it's complicated
so okay thank you very much
unfortunately we can't answer the all
the rest of the questions but assay is
around i think she will be happy if you
approach her and ask more questions
about this topic thank you very much
thank you for being here yeah and thank
you for